royang another big victory for you in
the last round it's always nice to
finish with a bang but also I think with
this one you have great chances to
finish second how would you assess your
I don't care anymore I'm just like with
the way my tournament started I'm just
glad I did this like I got here
absolutely absolutely and you will also
probably be getting an invitation based
on your rating to the US Women's Chess
Championship how are you seeing that
play out for you um
honestly I will be more worried about
like school like I've been missing like
two weeks of school I'm taking like a
lot of eight piece next year too so
are you ready to go to college soon or
like what's up yeah I'll be a junior
next year Junior next year so still have
a few years left before College a year
or so that was just impressive Stellar
play in the last few rounds I have to
say you're just like dominating your
opponents uh despite the fact that you
started slow you finish strong and
that's what matters congratulations guys
any questions
absolutely uh just to say it was a great
event I enjoyed watching your games and
congratulations you're young for a nice
finish second place in the tournament it
was a big field you you're not exactly a
favorite when Carissa and Alice is in
the field but you must be pleased with
your performance
I am thank you thank you yeah
congratulations very nicely exactly uh
Patrick Wolfe and uh